hi welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and on the first day of
February of Black History Month Netflix
released a little Sizzle of everything
that's coming out in 2024 the lineup is
stacked with things we've been waiting
for anticipating and things we low-key
forgot about this video is sponsored by
Squarespace the all inone platform that
makes launching your own website a
breeze in this video we'll go through
this Sizzle and talk about the shows
what's getting the hot buzz and where we
left off with some of these programs
because squid gang came out like a
little bit over two years ago and the
reality show really had us in a
different kind of Chokehold so let's try
to remember where we're at additionally
I'll be going through these with my
honest opinion of whether or not I'm
going to watch it or if I recommend it
cross my heart and I hope you guys are
into it and if you're not I'm sorry be
sure to check out nerd rot. shop to
check out the latest and greatest and
new rockstars merch right now you can
grab your Multiverse tour shirt
featuring many eras of Deadpool it's
like a Taylor Swift t-shirt I wouldn't
know I don't know Taylor Swift it also
comes out as a hoodie or a crop top or
maybe pick up our Madam web shirt
featuring the greatest line from any
movie trailer in history I hate this
line Gra ring some nerd From Nerd ride.
shop is the best way to support the
channel and all the work we do here for
you at new rock stars and how I get to
tell you what you should be watching in
2024 so let's get into it the series and
film preview opens with Atlas and just
like you I didn't know what this movie
was either a science fiction Thriller
directed by the man who did Journey to
Rampage and San Andreas so clearly it's
like The Rock's best friend starring JLo
who is you know JLo sometimes she's a
Shanti simu from shuni and sterley K
Brown another Marvel but we all love
them JLo is just also really making a
comeback this year which
okay okay I guess it follows Atlas a
military intelligence officer who has
spent years pursuing Intergalactic
terrorist Harland who murdered her
family things go south quickly when
their ship is struck by missiles and
she's forced to Dawn an AI driven
mechanical armored suit and I love
sci-fi and futuristic worlds this
actually seems very interesting and I
think with that cast it can be
adventurous and chaotic I'm just on the
fence and I'll be honest it's because
they put JLo in it I'm I'm sorry but it
does seem interesting next we move on to
the Diplomat the first season left off
on a cliffhanger that had the fans
anticipating a second season season and
it's starring Carrie Russell from the
American y'all we all need to be tuned
into this I don't watch many political
dramas unless we talk in Scandal or The
West Wing and this show is created by
the same person who did some work on The
West Wing so you know it's probably a
good show in the Diplomat Ambassador
Kate Wier Carrie Russell arrives in
London after a British aircraft carriers
blown up off the coast of Iran Kate
spends the whole first season of the
drama making allies and some enemies
while trying to figure out who's behind
the attack I'll be tuning in speeding up
dropping down dropping and I'm watching
this this is going to be a great show
next preview is black does this is a spy
Thriller star in Kira nightly once you
say Kira nightly I'm S I sit down I shut
up and I listen real quick this is a
six-part series set in London at
Christmas time following the mother wife
and professional spy nightly who's been
giving Secrets up on her political
husband and when her secret lover is
assassinated she embarks on a new
mission of who did it I'm a little burnt
out on like spy things but like doesn't
mean this isn't going to be good the
show is created by Joe Barton who did
the Lazarus Project and I like that I
don't know I think I might be missing
this one because there's just so much
coming out but I do love Kiera nightly
I'm just a little burnt out and spy
stuff then we have a new movie starring
Cameron Diaz and Jamie Fox back in
Action years after giving up life as CIA
spies to start a family Emily and Matt
find themselves dragged back into the
world of Espionage when their cover is
blown this is directed and written by
Seth Gordon who directed Horrible Bosses
this also Stars Glenn Close did I say I
was burnt out on spy things because I'm
back in it I'm back in
Action it'll have like that dark humor
like Horrible Bosses and Cameron Diaz
and Jamie Fox both have great comedic
timing and I'm sure Jamie Fox will just
improv 90% of the time I'm going to
watch it it's a it's a movie it's
probably going to be quick I'm going to
be watching this Rebel Moon part two the
scar Giver drops April 19th so this is
the second part of Rebel Moon that was
released around Christmas last year
ritten and directed by Zack Snyder it
continues the Epic Saga of Kora and the
surviving Warriors as they prepare to
sacrifice everything fighting alongside
the brave people of belt to defend a
once peaceful Village who have lost
their own in the fight against the
mother world I know it got some heat
online but some people said Netflix
should have just released the SNY cut it
did feel like it was missing some pieces
does that mean I loved it no because I
didn't which is okay I also want him to
create something that doesn't separately
have to have its own like theatrical cut
and his own cut a long long time ago
director Cuts were like infrequent and a
rare treat you'd get on a DVD now it
just feels just noisy like anytime we
say director's cut the only thing that
comes to my mind is the SNY cut and I
don't want that I want it to be other
things Snider fans can't come at me cuz
I stand by Sucker Punch and that is
probably his worst thing give me a
second one I will star in it Griselda
that released this year starring Sophia
vagara the biographical crime drama is
inspired by the Griselda Blanco a woman
who created a huge career in the cartel
as a drug lord it has the same Vibe as
narcos and painkiller because it uses a
lot of the same team behind it I watch
this and it is very violent and
aggressive and I've never seen Sophia
vagara play a role like that I didn't
know much of Grisel de Blanco and I'd
recommend looking into her before
watching the series and also looking
into the series itself if you like
violent cartel like dramas I'd recommend
it it's six episodes an hour long each
but trigger warning because there's a
lot of stuff that happens in this that's
horrible to watch for the newer
generation as Netflix says we have Outer
Banks it's new season it's releasing
season 4 of this show I did not even
know they got to season 4 another
Netflix returning favorite Outer Banks
is a Coming of Age story that
essentially Falls a group of teens on an
island that search for treasure that the
main character's dad disappeared looking
for allegedly it's filled with teen
Ang's drama and loads of suspense
because there's a lot of lying deception
and love going around if you're like me
and you like watching like teen dramas
and angsty stuff you're probably going
to find this frustrating uh I'll be
honest I was very irritated with their
dumb decisions but I love the first
season it's a delight the union Premier
in August 16th 2024 is an upcoming
American action thriller story Mark
Walberg and Hal Berry Mike played by
Mark Wahlberg a down toe construction
worker from New Jersey is quickly thrust
into the world of super spies and secret
agents when his high school
ex-girlfriend roxan Ali Barry recruits
him for a high stakes us intelligence
Mission I thought this was a comedy does
that not sound like a comedy I I I think
I'm just going to politely pass I love
Hal Berry though you know rock on girl
but I'm not watching the show Bridgerton
split into two parts part one coming May
16th and part two coming June 13th if
you know me which you all do you know
I'm a little freak for Bridger 10 this
is techn technically season 3 because
Queen Charlotte was sort of like a
spin-off but if you want to include it
it's Four Seasons overall if you like
down and Abby Pride and Prejudice and
the guilded age like me you're going to
like Bridgton this fall is a small town
of prestigious families all looking to
get rich get married and gossip I'm a
romantic freak so I eat this up if
you are to you'll like it you know I'll
be tuning in Cobra Kai the final season
one of everyone's favorites Netflix
labeled it under the returning favorites
Cobra Kai is unfortunately on its final
season and when we thought all was good
at the finale of the last season it was
revealed at the end Cree faked his own
death to escape prison Pres presumably
to take back Cobra Kai so the bad guy is
back and if you're already watching
Cobra Kai you're going to be watching it
this season I'm going to be watching it
this season then we get Sweet Tooth in
its final season I like the first season
and I really like the comic by Jeff
lamir the show is going to hit its third
and final season the series takes place
in a post-apocalyptic world where a boy
who is half boy half deer searches for
his home with his new protector this is
a fantasy drama that feels more grounded
than most fantasies it's kind of sad and
tugs at your heartstrings humans fear
and hate him and the long journey always
becomes treacherous I need to go back
and watch this show it's very hard for
me because I I'm very sensitive it made
me cry a lot in the first season but the
third is its final one so we should all
try tuning into this the Umbrella
Academy the final season a returning
favorite a show we will finally be
covering at new rockstars because I'm
back and I love this show it's a sad
Bittersweet end with its fourth season
being its final season because we all
really like this show it's based on the
comic book series Umbrella Academy
follows a unique family of once orphan
children all who have incredible Powers
but we last left off with the last
season of Umbrella Academy and the
sparrow Academy members have to reset
Reality by going to the hotel Oblivion
by the end of the finale after the reset
everyone is healed but their powers are
all gone they immediately split up
instead of figuring it out but in the
post credit scene Ben is spotted riding
what seems to be the same Korean train
that he was spontaneously born on we see
them back together in Clips but God I
don't know what's going on I don't know
what's going to happen I'm very excited
and I will be watching and breaking down
Beverly Hills Cop Axel F July 3rd 2024
this is bringing back the old school
Beverly Hills Cop movies this time he's
back after someone threatens his
daughter's life and his partner is
Joseph Gordon levit who I haven't seen
in a long time and such a weird person
to pair him up with Billy Rosewood and
John tager are returning Kevin Bacon is
also listed under the key
cast this goes without saying I will be
watching this for the Nostalgia alone I
love Beverly Hills Cop and he's Still
rocking the Detroit Lions varsity jacket
the 67 Detroit Lions varsity jacket
Eddie Brock wears a similar one I think
and regardless I I I'll just be watching
if you're a New Year's resolution was to
finally get yourself a professional
looking website and you haven't gotten
around to it yet I've got good news
Squarespace is here to help Squarespace
is an all-in-one platform that provides
you with everything you need to do
whatever you need with your website
Squarespace has templates and designs
for pretty much everything so whether
you're making your very first website or
sprucing up one for the new year using
Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update content and
add features to fit your unique needs
for instance Squarespace makes it easy
to sell merch you can design your
products and save time and money by
letting Squarespace handle production
inventory and shipping it and if you're
selling any other kind of physical Goods
digital Goods or even Services
Squarespace makes it easy to build your
storefront and grow your business
business just head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com neww
rockstars to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain three
body problem drops March 21st inspired
by the novel The Three body problem The
Story begins in 1960s China when a young
woman makes a fiful decision that
reverberates across space and time into
the present day when the laws of nature
inexplicably unravel a tight-knit group
of brilliant scientists must join forces
with an unflinching detective to stop
Humanity's greatest threat three body
problems is an epic story that redefines
sci-fi drama with its layered mystery
and story of human connection starring
Benedict Wong AKA Wong from every Marvel
movie and series it's also starring Jess
Hong and Joe Von Ado I will be watching
this series because I think the trailer
looks great but dashel who has read the
books said the trailer does not look
good and that's where we cross because I
haven't read the books I love Benedict
Wong but also the series just looks
super eerie and suspenseful for me I
know it's hard to adapt such a big big
book and it's such a big idea I hope
they do it well I'm still going to tune
in I'm still going to tune in if you
guys read the book yell at me for not
reading the book but it seems dense and
dash is very smart and I'm not so I
don't think I could finish it in time
shout out to dashel Hitman starring
Glenn Powell drops June 7th 2024 with a
limited theatrical release this is an a
war screw ball comedy thriller But
ultimately a relationship movie when I
saw these clips I said what the hell's
going on this man is so pretty no matter
what you do to his face inspired by The
Unbelievable true story a straight lace
Professor discovers he has a hidden
talent as a fake Hitman he makes his
match in a client who steals his heart
and ignites a powdered keg of deception
delight and mixed up identities I
probably will not watch this too
ridiculous for me but I do support Glen
Powell and I hope other people do and
will watch it because I'm not going to
watch it damsel drops March 8th staring
Millie Bobby Brown from stranger things
the pieces I've seen of this movie make
me strongly interested not only because
it's a fantasy damsel sees Brown as a
dutiful well damsel who agrees to marry
handome Prince only to discover it was
all a trap she's then thrown into a cave
with a fire breathing dragon relying
solely on her wits and will to survive
we're living and watching her survive in
fight and you give me a fantasy movie
where a woman fights a dragon thrives
and survives I'm already in I also love
fantasy and Elish like mythical worlds
and have never HD that fantasy fatigue
yet like everyone else has so I'm
completely down and interested I'll be
watching it on March 8th American
primeval A limited six-part miniseries
Netflix says covers the birth of the
American West with violent collisions of
cultures religions and communities as
men and women fight and die for the
control of this new world traveling west
with her son Sarah joins a Mormon
Caravan headed in the same direction but
bloody conflict erupts between the
Native Americans and those claiming the
land for themselves lots of Western like
Frontier shows coming out Yellowstone 18
83 1923 it just feels like Netflix is
also trying to get their hands in that
pot and remember Netflix is all about
the award shows now so this they know
what they're doing I like a different
perspective though because the other
shows really showcase the white people
already stolen the land and putting them
in high regard maybe this one doesn't it
looks breathtaking Netflix never had a
problem shooting great scenery shots
like this the show might pop off for
awards with Pete Berg Eric Newman and
Mark L Smith behind it I'll probably
watch it this one is insane to me carry
on Staring Taran ederton Jason baitman
and Sophia Carson as a thriller that
follows a young TSA agent outsmarting a
mysterious traveler who blackmails him
into letting a dangerous package slip
onto a Christmas Eve flight the preview
of this was given Paul Blart I thought
it was supposed to be a comedy and then
I saw it and I was like oh this ain't a
comedy at all and that's why I'm not
going to be watching this uh I don't
need to watch this movie but other
people can have fun Santa is a six
episode biopic series starring Gabrielle
Leon the series will trace the career of
the three-time Formula One racing
champion eron Senna one of three
Brazilian drivers to become world
champion won three times won the 41
Grand Prix and held the record for the
most positions until 2006 unfortunately
he passed away in a tragic accident
during a race and I don't think I have
the emotional well-being to watch this I
will ball my eyes out so I don't think I
can but I it does look beautiful avatar
the Last air bender drops February 22nd
and based on the original animated
series that is available to watch all on
Netflix we know this show follows the
first season where Ang and his friends
travel to find him a mentor and harness
the skills of the Avatar I broke the
trailer down for the channel I'll be
breaking down the series again when it
drops certainly certainly will be
watching this certainly will be dropping
in for it six Triple H star and Carri
Washington is the upcoming American war
drama written and directed by Tyler
Perry based on an inspiring true story
of the first and only women's Army Corps
unit of color to be stationed overseas
during World War II I think Tyler Perry
is doing this because he's he's aiming
for those Awards this is written like
for awards season I like Carrie the
scenery looks great in these clips I
don't know I I think I'll be passing if
I have time I will watch it but
personally I'm not a big American war
drama person either I will be looking
into the story though because I I I have
to Eric starring Benedict Cumberbatch
Gabby Hoffman and mckenley belter II is
set in 1980s New York an emotional
Thriller that follows a man who is in
search of his 9-year-old son who
disappeared on his way to school and he
uses his son's blue monster puppet
clinging to it convinced if he can get
that puppet on TV his son will then come
home are you out of your mind of course
I'm watching this it's tragic yes but I
think Benedict Cumberbatch is really
going to chew this roll up I I I want to
see him do it I need to see him do it
unfrosted the Pop-Tart story drops May
3rd 2024 it's a movie star in Jerry
Seinfeld Melissa McCarthy Jim Gaffigan
Amy Schumer a ton of comedic actors and
directed by Jerry Seinfeld this is his
directorial debut this takes place in
Michigan 1963 Kelloggs and post sworn
serial Rivals raced to create a pastry
that will change the face of breakfast I
think this is interesting I feel like
with the movies like air Tetris Money
Ball we're going back to these big
biographical big money scheme like
movies they're certainly interesting to
watch even if the events are not
completely accurate Netflix is trying to
hop on that wagon which is fine I think
with this cast it'll be very funny and
like fi the show if you get a bunch of
good actors acting around Jerry it'll
make him look good so I think I'll
probably tune in it's a movie it'll be
quick but it better be good Formula 1
drive to survive has a new season this
is season six this is Dash's favorite
show it drops February 23rd I will say
you don't need to know much about F1 to
watch this show and it's still
entertaining takes you behind the scenes
to see how the drivers and how they
prepare James gay Reese who produced the
Academy Award doca is still the EP on
this show and I don't think I'm going to
watch it because I'm very afraid of F1
Formula driv I it scares the crap out of
me it doesn't need my views it has six
seasons it's doing great the night agent
the new season this is season two based
on the novel by Matthew cork according
to Netflix the night agent is a
sophisticated character-based action
thriller centering on a low-level FBI
agent who works in the basement of the
White House Manning a phone that never
rings until the night that it does
propelling him into a fast moving and
dangerous conspiracy that ultimately
leads all the way to the Oval Office a
mole in the Oval Office I haven't seen
this show but it sounds super fun if I
have time to watch 10 episodes about an
hour a piece I will I like the idea of
just a mole in the white house and just
like trying to figure that out political
drama maybe it is winning me back over
Love is Blind season 6 premiering weekly
on Valentine's Day this show is a
Netflix favorite everyone loves it about
singles who are looking for love
sometimes and most of the time in all
the wrong places this show brings me too
much anger to watch it some of the men
on this show piss me off so I'm not
going to be watching this show but you
guys can watch it it doesn't need me
watching it has a bunch of Seasons
Netflix is a joke Fest from May 2nd to
May 12th the preview gives us older
clips from other specials like Don Wong
and Gabriel glacius is older special so
I think this just like placeholders to
remind us more comedic shows are coming
then we have the Netflix Cup live event
the Netflix slam premiering some live
event some golf I will not be watching
but hey you can I don't really watch
Mini Sports especially golf don't know
what's going on there Emily and peris
season 4 starring Lily Collins this show
has been getting reviews lots of talk I
tried watching it I couldn't do it
though it's clearly doing something
right if it's got a fourth season and
I'm sorry I have to speed these up now
because I'm losing time for our biggest
most anticipated show everyone's talking
I'm talking you're talking squid Game
season 2 no release date yet but
definitely this year God please do not
push this have it come out in 2024 we
see s ji hung and the recruiter gang Yu
and a new character played by Park Y
Young from the tidbits it looks colorful
for such a depressing story it looks
like jihun is still trying to take down
the games Netflix said he's abandoned
his plans to the US and starts a Chase
with a motive I assume to the guy who
led and organized the big money Stakes
behind the game who we know is actually
returning and I can't wait for this
breakdown once we get more footage for
the trailer because I love this show
we're all anticipating it that reality
show was too much bring me back season 2
there are a lot of big takeaways so much
in this Sizzle and these were a lot of
my takes but I'd love to hear yours tell
me if there's shows I should revisit or
watch because it was on your list I'm
clearly excited for Avatar Bridgerton
and Squid game follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at lulor Clemens follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
check out the break room and the Deep
dive and I'll see you
later
[Music]